you dedicate your 1985
touring award lecture to the memory of
your father
what's your fondest memory of your dad
seeing him standing in front of a class
at the blackboard drawing perfect
circles
by hand and
showing his his ability to
attract the interest of the motley
collection of
eighth grade students that he was
teaching
when when did you get a chance to see
him draw the perfect circles
uh on rare occasions he i i would get a
chance to
sneak into his classroom and observe
observation and i think he was at his
best in the classroom i think he really
came to life
and had fun um not only teaching
but uh but um
you know engaging in chit-chat with the
students and you know
ingratiating himself with the students
and
what i inherited from that is
the great desire to be a teacher i
retired recently
and a lot of my former students came
students whose with whom i had done
research or who had read my papers or
who
had been in my classes and when they
talked about
about me
they talked not about my
1979 paper or my 1992 paper but about
what they what came away in my classes
and not just the details but just the
approach and the
the manner of teaching
and so i sort of take pride in the
at least in my early years as a faculty
member at berkeley
i was exemplary in preparing my lectures
and i always came in
prepared to the teeth and able therefore
to deviate according to what happened in
the class
and to really
really provide a model for the students
so is there advice you could give out
for others on how to be a good teacher
so preparation
is one thing you've mentioned being
exceptionally well prepared but there
are other things
pieces of advice that you can impart
well the top three would be preparation
preparation and preparation
why is preparation so important i guess
uh is uh
it's because it gives you the ease to
deal with any situation that comes up in
the
in the classroom and you know
if you're if you discover that you're
not getting through one way you can do
it another way
if the students have questions you can
handle the questions
ultimately you're also feeling the
the the crowd the students of what
they're struggling with what they're
picking up just
looking at them through the questions
but even just through their eyes
yeah and because of the preparation you
can uh you can dance
you can dance you can you can
say it another way or give another angle
are there
in particular ideas and algorithms that
computer science do you find
were big aha moments for students were
they
for some reason once they got it it
clicked for them and they fell in love
with computer science
or is it individual is it different for
everybody it's different from everybody
you have to work differently with
students some
some of them just don't really don't
need much
influence you you know they they're just
running with what they're doing and they
just need an
ear and now and then others need a
little prodding
others need to be persuaded to
collaborate among themselves rather than
working alone
they have their personal ups and downs
so you have to
have to deal with each student as a
human being
and bring out the best
humans are complicated yeah perhaps a
silly question
if you could relive a moment in your
life outside of family
because it made you truly happy or
perhaps because it changed the direction
of your life in a profound way
what moment would you pick i was kind of
a lazy student
as an undergraduate and even in my first
year in graduate school and
i think it was when i started doing
research
i had a couple of summer jobs where i
was able to contribute
and i had an idea
and then there was one particular course
on mathematical methods in operations
research
where i just gobbled up the material and
i scored 20 points higher than
anybody else in the class then came to
the attention of the faculty
and it made me realize that i had some
ability
some ability that was going somewhere
uh you realize you're pretty good at
this thing
i don't think there's a better way to
end it richard it was a huge honor thank
you for
decades of incredible work thank you for
talking thank you it's been a great
pleasure
and uh you're a superb interviewer
i'll stop it
you